120 feminicidios en Francia en lo que va
de 2022 según los datos de la
organización feminista nuttud es un 20%
más de los números registrados en 2021 Y
ante este contexto cerca de 100.000
mujeres salieron a las calles de París
para protestar la única solución es
marchar hacer un poco de ruido y decir
Sí en cuenta porque somos la mitad de la
humanidad y si tenemos que marchar
marcharemos
entre las asistentes también hubo
presencia de víctimas
Hoy puedo hablar y estar aquí física y
emocionalmente y quiero hacerlo por
todas las mujeres que actualmente están
sufriendo tanto que no pueden hacerlo
además de los gritos y pancartas de
protesta las manifestantes socializaron
sus peticiones como 2.000 millones de
euros del presupuesto del estado con los
que disponer de más recursos legales y
también de asistencia para las víctimas
de violencia de género o más educación
deberíamos enseñar a hombres y mujeres
sobre el consentimiento que no significa
no y que no siempre debe ser respetado
no significa No no es negociable Y eso
realmente debe ser entendido por
nuestras parejas la organización
convocante de la marcha denuncia que el
80% de los casos de violencia doméstica
se archivan mientras Dos de cada tres
casos de acoso sexual no se manejan
correctamente con solo un 0,6% de los
violadores condenados